^- Let me put this away.
- I wanna play a different game.
(laughing)
- And then Yahtzee, Yahtzee, Yahtzee!
- Alright, so Would You Rather guys.
- Okay.
- Nice catch.
- Thanks guys.
- Wait who wants to go first?
I don't wanna--
- Kick it off.
You got the bucket.
- Yeah you do it, you got the bucket.
- I see nothing but confidence with you.
^- Okay thank you.
^I think I'd rather be single for the rest of my life though.
(laughs)
- I could do the vampire thing.
It sounds kinda sexy.
Wait Andy didn't answer that.
- It doesn't, no one cares (laughs).
- I care, I care.
(laughing loudly)
- I care.
^- I would do the single one--
- The single one, okay.
^- That one.
^- Oh wait.
^- Are you kidding me?
^- Never have pizza again.
- Never have pizza again?
Never have pizza--
- I would never, ever have pizza again.
I don't wanna be a gargoyle.
- I don't need to eat pizza guys.
I am undiagnosed lactose intolerant
so I think I can let go of the pizza anyway--
- You could let go of the pizza, okay.
- Yeah I don't need it.
- I don't know.
- You like pizza a lot.
- I do.
- You do really enjoy pizza.
- Yeah I do.
- What would you do as a gargoyle for 24 hours?
- I would love to not do anything for 24 hours.
- But that's the best--
- Are you afraid of heights though?
- No.
- Oh, well then.
- And is it like a living gargoyle?
Do I get to fly?
- What do you mean a living gargoyle?
- Like you're not a gargoyle statue.
- Oh.
- Wait a minute, how's the gargoyle go?
(caws like a crow)
- So are gargoyles crows?
They're really just fat crows.
If I get to fly, I'm in.
^- Oh.
- Oh that's tough.
- I don't think I'd wanna live forever.
- If you could look like this forever.
- Yeah.
- This is good.
- Thanks.
- Right?
If you could do this forever--
- That's so nice.
- You wouldn't do this forever?
- No.
- A little bit like there was a question mark in there.
- I could barely do it now.
(laughing loudly)
- Listen there are humans that live in 150 degree heat.
- That's true.
- Yeah I was born in Texas
so it's just kinda close.
- This is not, you're doing it
you've done it anyway.
- Yeah.
- You've already done it.
- I could do it.
- Vampires technically can be killed.
Stake through the heart.
- Oh.
- Flaw in that question.
Who wrote that question?
- When you knew it was time to call it.
- You could just go "hand me the stake".
It's just the summers.
It's just the three to four month big deal.
- Oh 150 degrees.
- It's 150 degrees.
- Glad we got to the bottom of this guys.
- Thank goodness.
- You know what it was is I was trying so hard to read
the question really well that I didn't really
focus on the details.
- That you didn't take in the content.
- Happens a lot at my Passover seder.
^- (laughs) Totally.
^- Oh that's too much work.
To do this.
- This, yeah yeah.
Nobody needs that big of quad.
- One eye on the bottom of my foot no question.
- Yeah.
- I don't know I'll try all of the eyes.
- I'm going one on the bottom of the foot
because otherwise you're just bumping into stuff
^and you're getting jacked in your eyes all the time.
^- I would say my most recent ex hands down.
- Yeah, me too.
- Yeah.
^- Me too.
^- Oh God I can't take it in.
^- Werewolf.
^- Werewolf and I would exclusively hook up with wolves
so that when I changed they'd be like now we're talking.
- Exactly, wait a second.
- It'll be like a surprise.
- Oh this human person I guess I'll do one kiss.
- Oh I didn't know.
(singing)
- That's good.
You and I are the best singers here.
(laughing loudly)
- We could teach everyone here a little thing
or two about singing.
- Ooh!
^- Oh.
- Oh the blood for sure.
- Ooh.
- What?
(group gasps)
- Whoa whoa whoa, the blood?
- That was a surprise, I love it!
- I've been to the hospital so much so it's kind of
comforting in a weird way.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah.
- To drink your own blood?
- Yeah why not?
- Forced to sleep upside down?
- I don't wanna sleep upside down.
That's probably gonna be bad for me.
- Well it's like drinking your own blood cause
it's all gonna go to your head anyway.
- I just think of like hot blood.
- Can I chill it with some ice?
- Yeah that's what I was gonna say.
Can we drink it with ice?
- Add water, balance it.
- So maybe it's like everyday I know I'm gonna barf
blood but then I'm gonna sleep really well.
- See?
- You were right.
^- Thank you.
- Yeah, no you're right, yeah.
^- Graveyard.
^- Oh God.
- Graveyard.
^- Yeah.
- Graveyard, graveyard.
^- For sure.
- Graveyard.
- And it would be very respectful of those around me.
- Absolutely yeah.
- Oh I would sleep in a graveyard.
Actually it feels very, it sounds very relaxing to me.
^- Oh we have one more.
^- Zombie apocalypse.
- Oh yeah zombie apocalypse.
^- I love zombie movies.
- We've got all the rules.
We can handle a zombie apocalypse.
That's not even an issue.
- Are you guaranteed to survive it?
- It's not details you'll also survive everything.
- It clearly implies that you would.
- I'm saying that if there's any chance I'm
gonna get attacked by zombies and turn into a zombie
I might choose no music.
- There's only 723 movies.
Like we just have an instruction manual out there already
of how to handle zombies.
There's a whole TV show.
- But a lot of those movies end with most of the
characters as zombies.
- That's true.
They get eaten, they get eviscerated, or zombified.
- Except for like a cute couple and they're gonna start
a family and that's gonna begin again the human race.
- Yeah I could be that.
- That could be you, Selena, that could be you.
- Well we did great here.
- (laughs) Oh you guys.
- I think we've solved some problems.
- Riveting.
- We got through it guys.
- Think tank, think tank.
- Can we keep these lobs?
- (laughs) These are ours right, to keep?
Thanks guys, that was awesome!
(fast techno music)